This type of statistical analysis is prone to misinterpretation. As we
discussed in the last solution video, it's possible that those who were able to
view the musical lesson happened to be more engaged students already and we
wrongly attributed the high mean engagement score to the song. Of course it's
unlikely we found the probability of getting that sample mean engagement score
was about 0.007, but it's still possible to have randomly obtained a sample
with that mean. But this means that one of four things can happen, here's a
diagram that's no completely filled out, but it shows the four possible things
that can happen. The columns represent the decision we made, we either rejected
the null or retained the null, based on, the results of our sample. The state
of the world is, what is actually happening. And we don't know what it is.
We're just making a guess. Either the null is true, that there is not any
significant effect from the treatment, or the null is false. There is a
significant effect. Each of these four boxes represents a different situation.
The truth, and then the decision we made. In two of these four cases, we made
the correct statistical decision, but in the other two, we made the wrong
decision. Check the two cases in which we've made the wrong statistical
decision.